I was watching your Oscar speech the
other night yeah
you know I knew you were coming in I
said let me watch that Oscar speech cuz
I'm glass was one of the most emotional
Oscar speeches ever so when you won the
Oscar you were like 27 years old right
I was 26 26 yeah which is young very and
shocking because you go into acting and
that's the that's the Holy Grail to win
an Oscar yeah it was pretty crazy I mean
I think my dad was very sick and my
grandfather was dying and and I was so I
just I was so overwhelmed and is it hard
to be happy when you like your parents
were sitting next to you at the Oscars
yeah which was really sweet yeah and
your mom life Danner
yes I'm a fan of I know and your father
yes we're sitting there next to you and
they announced that you beat out Meryl
Streep and all these people and you were
gracious you said hey Meryl you're the
greatest actress of all time I can't
believe I beat you but I beat you [ __ ]
you but was was it a bittersweet moment
because everyone in your life was
because you were really emotional it was
genuine yeah
I was very I just I think I had so much
emotion and so many different kinds of
emotion and it was like I couldn't
contain it in my body my father had gone
through such a hard time and he was
sitting next to me in cancer yeah did
you know he was dying was it no no he
had had this big surgery and radiation
and had a very hard time recovering and
what's weird is when you what do you
have a watch have you ever gone back and
watched your speech no oh why would that
mortify you yes beyond why because why
well first of all I I don't like hearing
the sound of my voice
I don't like watch it like I can't watch
myself in a movie I just I don't know I
just know what I want to ask you like
the swing when you're up for an Oscar
yeah this what I didn't understand you
had your hair pulled all the way back in
a really tight hairstyle like almost
making you bald and I'm like why is
through yeah I was like who decided that
Gwyneth Paltrow wears this gorgeous long
blonde flowing mane why did they make
you pull your I don't know
I think well at the time you know you're
26 and you're sort of being like I had
the top
I had Kevin o Quan who was the top
makeup guy at the time and Orlando Peeta
who still liked that one of the top hair
guys in the world I always noticed when
women get married they pull their hair
they pull their hair back in a tight bun
and I go wait a second I've never seen
you I'm marrying you I've never seen you
with your hair pulled like that like why
does everyone assume that so should I
not wear my hair back no I mean you look
beautiful no matter what your gorgeous
woman but I just I saw you is young
you're in your twenties yeah I think you
know to be honest it was just a very
very intense time all around and you
know you're going to be super
scrutinized and I just kind of went with
the how much how much how much goes into
that night like what you're gonna wear
and what you're going to to look like
quite a lot yeah and and and like does
the movie studio get involved and I
think they pay for everything you know
they pay for your hair and makeup and
then I can't the dress I can't it I
think it was now it's like it's such an
industry right around like who's wearing
what and getting people to wear your
brand on the red carpet especially at
the Oscars I think at the time it was
slightly more mellow than that and I
remember I remember just seeing this
pink because I didn't have a stylist or
anything and I was looking at pictures
like what am I gonna wear to the Oscars
and I said this pink ball gown skirt
that Ralph Lauren had done with like a
cashmere sweater and I thought that
would be I wish I had known you back
then you were what would you have told
me I would you can something more
youthful like yeah you don't think a
bubblegum pink dress is useful but it
was more like I think I just I mean who
knows I was 26 years old
did you have that speech written out
because I mean it seemed like you were
pretty spontaneous
you know I had nothing written out and I
was really surprised when I heard Jack
Nicholson say my name and what a rush